a year after is surprising victory
Brazilian President Jerry bull scenario
has failed to deliver on his most
radical promises and managed enough wins
to keep them alive the former Army
captain a self-confessed nostalgic for
the Brazilian dictatorship has blamed
the democratic checks and balances in
his country for slowing down his dream
of freeing Brazil of what he calls the
ideology of the left and globalization
while pushing for his pro-gun Pro
religion agenda a third of the country
remains delighted with his ideas but
many seem to have had second thoughts he
was rather inexperienced and throughout
this year he has had many specific
problems scandals and so on which
haven't allowed him perhaps to build or
to maintain that high level of
popularity
he's been at loggerheads with
international organizations as he played
down the devastation of the Amazon
rainforest with a 76 percent increase in
fires compared to the previous year
domestically it has also been a
turbulent time promises of legalizing
the caring of arms and offering immunity
to police carrying out lethal operations
were rejected by Congress or halted by
the Supreme Court corruption scandals
involving his sons damaged his image as
a crusader against corruption and the
country's powerful farming Lobby forced
him to push down as anti China
anti-communist rhetoric yet managed to
pass historic pension reform after
decades of failed attempts to tackle
Brazil's sky-high public debt
I think some of his main promises that
were related to security to the ability
to to you know to have a guns and things
like that haven't turned out to be so
successful or so important I think
what's what's happening if you if you
read public opinion and so on is that
the focus is moving you know surprise
surprise towards the economy what if you
know is international supporters still
hope you will be able to tackle drug
gangs and crime but to further his
vision the key will be
lysing a SIL sluggish economy a year
later it's unclear what you'll be able
to achieve but few doubt he'll remain as
controversial as ever
alison ramp et al Jazeera